hey guys welcome back to a brand new
Veda we're back on apex legends again
and we actually have a little bit of a
teaser coming from season two with the
new character Watson as people have
speculated so it was always like the
beefy do enjoy subscriber for new I
covered the informational side of apex
legends to keep everybody up to date on
what's happening within the world of
apex legends so that no one ever misses
out on an update as well as covering the
lore of all the characters and apex
legends as well as the new hero earned
the new character we're gonna be talking
about which I'll get into in a little
bit after this intro was done see I was
always like to me if you do enjoy my
Twitter and discord to be in the
description down below and let's get
started with this TV
so first up as I said this is a teaser
for the new character coming in season 2
which is I believe going to be Watson as
if the leaks are correct I'll show the
video a couple times first then we're
gonna be going over what it says and we
can speculate and talk about some stuff
yeah that was the quick gift there's no
audio of course because it is a gift but
it does say apex legends EA play at
Hollywood Life from the Hollywood
pallidum iam on EA dot-com Saturday June
8th at 10:00 a.m. I do not actually know
what time zone they're in I do believe
since it is in Hollywood California it's
most likely going to be in the PT time
so if you're in the Eastern Standard
Time like me it's gonna be around 1 p.m.
on Saturday June 8th so I will
definitely be covering all that for you
guys
but as for the leak we've had some
interesting stuff to talk about as well
as this tease like I said so yeah real
quick I'm just gonna freeze the image on
exactly what this shows it shows the new
character watching throwing some
electricity between his hands I'm
assuming this isn't something he was of
course born with this is probably
something with his suit that allows him
to do this stuff but yeah this is the
new character a lot a long time ago I
think before even octane release we had
tons of leaks coming out about
characters and their names and we all
assumed that whoever had the most amount
of leaks it was going to be the newest
hero and at the time we had a ton of
leaks on what octane was going to be and
who didn't guess what octane came to the
game so that happen to be true the next
character that had the more amounts of
leaks as time went on was Watson this
exact character right here from the past
leaks he has some type of electrical
defying field of electricity some type
of fence or something that he can place
down and maybe cut off choke points as
well as some other stuff like
of course this is all just speculation
but so far everything seems to be true
and as we can kind of tell he has some
electricity going through his hands so
we can obviously just interpret that
that leak is gonna be true with his
electric fence ability it most likely
will be his ultimate as in terms of what
a passive ability he's going to get or a
tactical ability or anything like that
we have no idea I don't even know what
the hell is going on with his hands I've
no clue what he's doing here he's just
tossing lightning there's really nothing
he's doing he's not showing some type of
ultimate or anything like that but still
looks absolutely incredible yeah there
really isn't much to talk about within
this video just a very quick 2 second
clip I just wanted to share with you
guys what that is gonna be and with the
new character you know what his armor
earned his suit is gonna look like we
don't have a face yet there was of
course at least about what the face
would be but that was a very low poly
textured very poorly edited type of
photo that was of course taken from
files and stuff so there is nothing
confirmed in it what he looks like or
what that it could be a heat could be
she I have no idea beyond the comments
below guys since it's gonna be the end
of the video I want you to let me know
in the comments what you guys think of
this new leak I think Watson's gonna be
an incredible character I like the fact
that there's a little bit of play on
words with his name it being Watson
Watson is usually spelled with one T but
since he deals with electricity and
watts which is W ATT I like how they did
that with his name that was really nice
of those developers to do that I'm not
entirely sure just basing off of how
electric electricity in this field if
the electricity field is supposed to be
his actual ultimate I think he's gonna
be a pretty nice character in apex
legends cutting out choke points from
the inside and in buildings and stuff
but on in a big area I don't think it's
gonna do much I have a feeling he might
be a pretty good hero or a pretty good
legend ever in the very beginning when
he releases but as people understand how
the character is gonna be I don't think
he's gonna be too terrible or but really
not that good either but that's just my
personal opinion be a guys like the V if
you do enjoy subscribe for new like I
said I cover the informational side of
apex legends to make sure everyone is
up-to-date on what's happening within
the world of a Plex legends as well as
covering the lore and do not worry I
will definitely cover the lore of Watson
because I'm super intrigued on where
this man came from or woman we don't
discriminate here we have that sounds
interesting stay subscribe to the
channel my two most recent videos are
gonna be popping up on screen if you
guys do want to check that out but that
guy's hope ever grows today thank you
for watching the video let me know what
you guys think about the teaser in the
comments below
and take care
[Music]
you
[Music]